what do you think in general about the
all the exciting advancements of uh
Transformer uh neural networks
most beautifully uh Illustrated through
the large language models like gpt4
like everybody else we're all you know
I'm I'm surprised at uh how much uh how
far they've come
um I'm a little bit nervous about the
there's anxiety around them obviously
for I think good reasons right uh
disinformation is a a curse that's a an
unintended consequence of social media
that could be
exacerbated with these tools so if you
use them to deploy this information it
could be a real risk
um but I also think that the risks
associated with these kinds of models
don't have a whole lot to do with the
way we're going to use them in our
robots if I'm using a robot
I'm building a robot to do you know a
manual task of some sort
um I can judge very easily is it doing
the task I asked it to is it doing it
correctly there's sort of a a built-in
mechanism for judging is that is it
doing the right thing did it
successfully do the task yeah physical
reality is a good verifier it's a good
verifier that's exactly it whereas if
you're asking for yeah I don't know
you're trying to ask a theoretical
question in chat GPT
it could be true or it may not be true
and it's hard to have that verifier what
what is that truth that you're comparing
against whereas in physical reality you
know the truth
and this is an important difference and
um so I'm not
I think there is reason to be a little
bit concerned about
um
you know how these tools large language
models could be used but I'm not very
worried about how they're going to be
used
well how learning algorithms in general
are going to be used on on robotics it's
it's really a different application
that has different ways of verifying
what's going on well the nice thing
about language models is that
um I ultimately see
I'm really excited about the possibility
of having conversations with spot yeah
uh there's no I would say negative
consequences to that but just increasing
the bandwidth in the variety of ways you
can communicate with this uh particular
robot so you can communicate visually
you can communicate through some
interface and to be able to communicate
verbally again with the beer and so on
um I think that's really exciting to
make that much much easier we have this
partner levitas that's adding the vision
algorithms for daydreading for us they
just just this week I saw a demo where
they hooked up you know a language tool
to spot and they're talking a spot to
give examples of it yeah can you tell me
about the Boston Dynamics AI Institute
what is it and what is its mission
so it's a separate organization uh the
Boston Annex artificial intelligence
Institute
and it's led by Mark raybert the founder
of Boston Dynamics and the former CEO
and my old advisor at MIT Mark has
always uh loved the research the pure
research without the confinement or
demands of commercialization
and uh he wanted to continue to you know
pursue that unadulterated research
and uh uh so uh suggested uh to Hyundai
that that he set up this institute and
they agree that it's worth additional
investment to kind of continue push
pushing this Forefront
and we expect to be working together
where you know Boston Dynamics is again
both commercialize and do research but
the sort of time Horizon of the research
we're going to do is you know in the
next let's say five years you know what
can we do in the next five years let's
work on those problems
and I think the goal of the AI Institute
is to work even further out
um certainly you know the analogy of of
legged Locomotion again when we started
that that was a multi-decade problem and
and so I think Mark wants to have the
freedom uh to pursue really hard Over
the Horizon problems and that's that'll
be the goal of the Institute